bonjour j'allais à l'achat oui merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors on
voit que la situation est toujours aussi
tendue dans le pays malgré donc cet
accord de cessez-le-feu trouvait en fin
de semaine dernière comment l'expliquez
vous ben un lien d'abord en fait deux
événements le cessez-le-feu nécessite
une interruption du blocus pétrolier qui
est maintenue par le côté la faction du
maréchalat retard depuis janvier de
cette année et il y avait évidemment un
lien direct entre les conséquences
économiques de ce blocus et le
mécontentement de la population au
niveau de l'ensemble du pays et en
particulier de la patte de la zone
particulièrement densément peuplées
key4it elle le camp du de khalifa haftar
qualifie ce cessez le feu comme un coup
médiatique de la part du gène à après
seulement trois jours le cessez le feu
pensez vous qu'il soit déjà d'ores et
déjà menacé oui il ya une façon
finalement qu'il a trouvé le camp de
maréchal haftar de dénigrer c'était le
feu citant le rejeter et c'est un petit
peu la zone grise qu'il a pu trouver
assez savamment depuis hier soir dont
techniquement on va les regretter
d'avoir rejeté le cessez le feu mais
c'est évidemment l'idée l'idée c'est de
faire perdre crédibilité à cette
initiative avant même qu'elle soit
sortie de l'oeuf et pourquoi ce cessez
le feu semble-t-il si compliqué à mettre
en place à cause du nombre d'acteurs
internationaux déjà ne serait-ce que
cela est aussi l'imbrication extrêmement
étroite entre le caractère économique de
la crise et le caractère militaire s'il
est aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
conventionnelle que pendant la première
moitié de 2009 en le moyen d'expression
du maréchal haftar c'est d'abord avant
tout le blocus pétroliers c'est ce qui
lui permet d'être anglais la capitale
tripoli
mais aussi par la même occasion ensemble
du pays mais il y a donc une accalmie
n'a qu'à me vient aussi avec un retour
des des vieilles lignes de fractures
notamment toujours dans tripolitaine
dans la zone qui est censé être contrôlé
par le gouvernement de tripoli
il ya de vieilles rancunes qui
aujourd'hui peuvent s'exprimer plus
facilement que pendant un à période
d'offensive de la part du maréchal tard
dans la zone de tripoli une offensive
qui a été interrompue et cassée début
juin 2020 quelles sont ces vieilles
rancunes que vous évoquez il y a
toujours les miens les mêmes d'abord ya
des adhérents qu'une le local il ya
aussi la vieille vieil antagonisme entre
islamistes non islamiste voire anti
islamiste qui quand même ont combattu le
match en retard pour des raisons tout à
fait égaux east mais maintenant que la
campagne militaire du marais chez
remstar a été rompu comme je le disais
hé bien il faut qu'ils défendent leurs
intérêts contre certains acteurs qui
bénéficie de soutien turc par exemple
qui a tendance à voir une sympathie et
courants islamistes par exemple tout
cela est vrai et ça reste un élément
dominant mais j'insiste toujours dans le
facteur le facteur économique de la
crise est-ce que vous pensez que la
communauté internationale a un rôle à
jouer dans ce conflit dans le pays
la communauté internationale est très
divisée ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on pourra vais arriver à l'anis sikus
de du 21 août
il a fallu plusieurs morceaux de
diplomatie il a fallu le cordon de
communication existants en et moscou il
a fallu le travail des allemands qui ont
beaucoup aux vraies stars de l'onu des
américains est aussi une certaine bonne
volonté de la part de l'egypte tout cela
est venu ensemble pour produire le petit
peu relativement prometteur du 21 août
donc il n'y a pas vraiment de communauté
internationale ont des îlots parfois
essaye de trouver un alignement
il ya aussi
d'heure comme les arabes unis -
intéresse matic pensez vous que
l'organisation d'élections prochaine ans
comme annoncé par les deux autorités
pour à pois ce faire ou est ce que c'est
ça laisse un portrait des sessions
parlementaires ne sont pas impossibles
contrairement à des élections
présidentielles comme celles auxquelles
la france à bout 2018 jusqu'à mes 19
aujourd'hui cette idée de l'élection
présidentielle a été évacué les choses
que je trouve absolument souhaitable des
élections parlementaires c'est moins
polarisant c'est plus local le pays a
connu deux bonnes de relativement
réussie en terme de municipales par
exemple donc les la tenue logistique
électorale pourrait se perd peut-être
pas en mars 2021 en tout cas durant
l'année de 2021 je trouve que cet
objectif plausible
merci beaucoup jalel harchaoui pour
toutes ces précisions je rappelle que
vous êtes chercheur à l'institut clic
endel de la haye